FOR MORE WE GO TO OUR SENIOR
TEXAS AQUATICS CORRESPONDENT
JESSICA WILLIAMS.
SHE'S IN McKINLEY.
>> HI, JON, HELLO.
>> Jon: THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, JESSICA.
>> NO PROBLEM, JON, I'M JUST
GOING TO ANOTHER POOL PARTY.
(LAUGHTER)
HAT LOOKS LIKE FULL BODY ARMOUR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, OR AS AT
THE CALL IT HERE A McKINNEY
BIKINI.
>> Jon: A McKINNEY.
>> OH, JON, I LIKE THAT.
THIS WEEK'S INCIDENT HAS
TAUGHT BLACK PEOPLE SOMETHING
VALUABLE. IT'S THAT WHEN YOU
GO TO A POOL PARTY, EVEN IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD THAT YOU
LIVE IN YOU HAVE TO KNOW
POOL ET CAN THE QUESTION TO
RUNNING, NO SPLASHING, NO
TALKING BACK AND IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE GET YOUR ASS
FURTHER INTO THE GROUND THAN
IT IS.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, I MEAN
THIS WAS A POOL PARTY.
>> UH-HUH.
: IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE FUN, WATER
BALLOON, SUPER SOAKER.
>> A WATER GUN AT A TEXAS
POOL PARTY?
ARE YOU TRYING TO GET ME KILLED?
>> Jon: NO, IT'S TEXAS.
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS WAVING
GUNS AROUND.
>> NO, WHITE PEOPLE ARE AND
THEY CALL IT OPEN CARRY.
FOR BLACK PEOPLE IT'S CALLED
HE'S GOT A GUN!
HE'S GOT A GUN HE'S GOT A
GUN!
>> Jon: JESSICA, ARE THESE
THINGS HAPPENING MORE AND
MORE, OR ARE WE JUST SEEING
IT MORE AND MORE BECAUSE OF
THE PREVALENCE OF CAMERA
PHONES.
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT EITHER
WAY THIS INCIDENT IS
PROGRESS.
>> Jon: IS-- I'M SORRY,.
>> WHAT?
>> Jon: A COP PULLED HIS GUN
OUT AND DRAGGED A
14-YEAR-OLD GIRL TO THE
GROUND BY HER HAIR.
>> YEAH, I KNOW, WHITE
PEOPLE ALWAYS WANT TO TOUCH
OUR HAIR, IT'S NOTHING NEW.
JON, IT'S PROGRESS BECAUSE A
COP PULLED A GUN ON A GROUP
OF BLACK KIDS AND NOBODY IS
DEAD.
AND AS A SHOW OF GOOD FAITH
OF THIS NEW ERA IN COMMUNITY
POLICING, CHICAGO HAS
ANSWERS.
>> IT'S A SHOOT-OUT ON THE
STREETS OF CHICAGO AT
POINT-BLANK RANGE.
BUT THOSE AREN'T GUNS,
THEY'RE FIREWORKS.
SPECIFICALLY ROMAN CANDLES.
>> SEEN STRAIGHT OUT OF
HARRY POTTER AS FIREWORKS
LIGHT UP THE NIGHT.
>> JON, IT'S BLACK KIDS
SHOOTING EACH OTHER IN
CHICAGO WITH HARMLESS ROMAN
CANDLES.
ALTHOUGH IT COULD ACTUALLY
BE A SCENE OUT OF HARRY
E THERE WERE BLACK PEOPLE IN IT.
>> Jon: WERE THERE REALLY NO
BLACK KIDSES AT HOGWARTS?
>> THERE WAS ONE, BUT FILCH SHOT
HIM.
THEY SAID HE PULLED OUT A
GUN BUT IT WAS JUST A STICK,
JON, IT WAS JUST A STICK.
HE GOT THEM CONFUSED.
>> IN FILCH'S HIS DEFENSE, THEY
LOOK VERY SIMILAR FROM THE A
DISTANCE.
>> EXCEPT ONE HAS A STRAND
OF UNICORN HAIR IN IT YOU
RACIST.
>> Jon: JESSICA, YOU LOVE THE
HARRY POTTER BOOKS.
>> OKAY, YOU'RE RIGHT, I DO,
M SORRY, I WASN'T INTO AUTOMATIC
GREIVENCE MODE.
PROGRESS. I DO LOVE JK ROWLING.
TOTALLY JKing ABOUT JK ROWLING.
NK YOU JESSICA THAT MAKES ME --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, THERE ARE
LLY THREE BLACK STUDENTS IN THE
BOOKS. THERES ANGELINA JOHNSON ,
LEE JORDAN AND DEAN THOMAS.
AND OF COURSE THERE KINGSLEY
SHACKLBOLT
WHO WAS IN THE ORDER OF THE
ORDER OF THE PHOENIX.
I ALSO REALLY LIKED THE CASUAL
VACANCY AND FELT LIKE--
WE'RE GONNA GO. JESSICA
WILLIAMS.